Welcome to the show.
Uh, in American news and politics, there are
major groundbreaking breaking
events only every few years.
So we've had nine 11, we've had the Iraq war
passing Obamacare, the first black president
and ignorant reality show host being elected
president, the national legalization of gay
marriage, a president impeached a few weeks
ago to sort of random and incomplete list.
But the idea is the truly major news stories
aren't every day the Iran fiasco that Donald
Trump is building up to, including maybe a
war with Iran on the proverbial Eve of his
reelection, could be one of those stories
as Donald Trump is increasingly unhinged,
desperate, impeached and trying to salvage
a second term by any means that he can concoct.
Now, as you may know by now, last week, Donald
Trump ordered and unauthorized his assassination
of the leader of the uranium includes Kaseem
Solemani.
His behavior is so turbulent.
Trump's that is so volatiles, so manic and
disturbed that the primary allies of the United
States are now clearly and publicly abandoning
Trump on this issue.
And by virtue of that abandoning the United
States on this issue, we are going to get
into all of this today.
The thin justification for the assassination,
if you can even call it a justification.
Um, the gaslighting and the lies that are
being told about Solemani, including that
he was linked to nine 11.
We're going to get to all of it, but I want
to sort of start with the consequences.
And one of those is that many of our key allies,
including the United Kingdom and Germany and
others are saying, stop.
They're saying, no, no, no, you can't do this.
We are not with you.
If this is what you are going to do.
The United Kingdom says that further conflict
is quote in none of our interests.
That's not totally true.
I mean, it might be in Donald Trump's interest
if he thinks it will help him, uh, get reelected.
And it actually may then it is sort of in
Trump's interest, but it's in very few other
people's interests.
Certainly military contractors seem to be
pleased about what's going on.
Uh, defense contractors.
Germany says that this is potentially a quote,
dangerous escalation.
They don't want it.
They are not with Trump and the United States.
France has been trying to restore sort of
logic and reason to the Iran nuclear deal
deal after Donald Trump unilaterally and without
any real reason bailed on the deal.
And we did this without consulting France
either and later we will get to Iran is now
saying they are totally out of the Iran nuclear
deal since Trump bailed on it anyway, so things
not going well there.
The secretary of state for European affairs,
Amelie demoed Chalan told a French radio station
that any unilateral action by the United States
was dangerous.
We did this without even telling our European
allies about this.
Now later, we'll get into this maybe tomorrow.
It appears that random guests at Donald Trump's
Mar-a-Lago resort knew more about what Donald
Trump was doing in Iraq to this Iranian leader
than our own congressional leadership and
our own European allies.
As former United States secretary of defense,
Robert McNamara once said, if we had chosen
during the Vietnam era not to do things unilaterally,
and without the support of our allies, we
never would have gone into Vietnam in the
first place.
And there are actually starting to be shades
of history on a few different fronts here.
So first is Vietnam, the unilateral way in
which Donald Trump seems willing to approach
Iran given his actions so far with Kaseem
Solemani hint at Vietnam.
That's one sort of a shaded history.
The propagandizing that we're already seeing
about it was an imminent threat.
Sola Mani was connected to nine 11 that is
reminiscent not of Vietnam, but of Iraq.
Um, and we're going to talk about the, the,
the similarities to the Iraq war propaganda
a little bit later on in the program today.
This is all bad.
And the only thing that the supporters of
Donald Trump's actions have, and there are
some on the right and there are actually some
on the left, believe it or not, that are defending
the actions of Donald Trump.
The only thing that they have is Sola.
Amani was a bad guy.
Well, nobody's denying that Solemani was responsible
for the deaths of Americans historically.
Well, that that's true.
It is not justification here for what Donald
Trump has done.
It is not justification for an unhinged unilateral
foreign policy that immediately gets our longtime
allies to say, Oh no, no, no, we don't want
anything to do with what's going on there.
And it seems that increasingly, uh, Donald
Trump is going to have the support of American
Republican senators, and that really may be
all he needs to get what he wants and to do
what he wants to do, which again, he sees
as something to distract from the fact that
he is an impeached president.
Something that is extremely embarrassing to
him, to the extent that he's able to feel
embarrassment.
And then that's a limited a sense.
And to the extent that he believes it will
help him to get reelected in 2020.
So let's now having sort of gotten to the
consequences first, which is our allies are
abandoning us.
Let's get into some of the sub on Trump.
Iran.
This includes the propaganda.
This includes information security justification,
the legality, the threats of war crimes that
Donald Trump is casually making on Twitter.
A lot of Iran stuff on today's program, which
by the way, I'm going to get to this later,
is not at all profitable for me, but I don't
want to get up, put the cart before the horse.
We'll get to that a little bit later.
Let's start with the justification for the
assassination of Kaseem Sola money.